le longues minutes de camions puis de la
marche avec le matériel sur le dos les
agents du glaive commence l'entretien du
sentier touristique du trou de faire ça
tu connais que ça n'a pas coupé les
seulement les apps côté ning mais ça y
est la sni de taille les boîtes de lait
bande 1800 et signe là se dit en
sécurité avant de travailler contrat
desenclos blaise secours union mais
d'après marc ont fait cette motivation
mais a renvoyé à la demande va et vient
parce qu'il voit mais qui les travaille
bien les agents du glay fonds et tfou
min formation qui a vu avant allant bof
quoi avec l'encadrement avec nos nerfs
bon à savoir identifier les principales
espèces les endémique et l'épaisse qu'on
retrouve dans le milieu
que tout ce qui est plutôt nettoyage
classique des bords avec l'insertion et
tout ce qui est un peu plus technique
sur le travail de
de l'eau de la gestion de l'eau pose de
marché tout on va faire plus tôt ça avec
nos ouvriers sylviculteurs polyvalent a
pris deux boîtes recouvert de graviers
plein bois le bois les tisanes sahara
mais les protégés de ça la roumanie
avait débouché yes d'épaulé et
ronchonner les manières et les sabres
toute l'année 85 agents du glaive
entretien de près de 400 kilomètres de
sentiers de notre forêt départementaux
domaniale entre le nord et l'est de
l'île et chaque sentier est entretenu
deux fois par an
s'il ya pas de motivation et c'est
difficile on a peu de gens qui
abandonnent mais ça peut être difficile
à gérone l'abandon on l'a au moment des
entretiens qu'ont fait avant la
signature du contrat
on voyait des gens une fois qu'on leur
expliquer ce que tu es le métier en
forêt ils signent pas contre en
cinquième chantier le plus fréquenté
avec une moyenne de 200 passages par
jour
le trou de fer il une des cartes
postales réunionnaise et la calomnie
passe comme ça un quota ou c'est grâce à
hausse et c'est travail l'équipe sa
décote de 10 grâce à nous nos vins
jamais besoin d'eux on le fait mais dans
l'autre besoin tiens qu'il est tombé le
bats toi les prochaines années l'année
prochaine on reviendra au moins bons
mois de l'année à vous mais là on est
dans une période où ballot nf
avec ses représentants du personnel
viennent de signer des accords pour en
fait un départ anticipé en retraite
donc on va voir nombre de personnes qui
devront répondre à ces critères donc on
va être obligé pour pour continuer
d'assurer nos missions pour le conseil
départemental
on va être obligé de recruter et le
vivier aulas le millier ont là il est
dans les les contrats d'insertion du
glèbe
ces agents qui acceptent ces conditions
de travail sont aujourd'hui dans un
processus qualifiant une démarche
entreprise par le glaive et ses
partenaires pour des emplois durables